the Islamic State of Iraq and Syria is a
phenomenon so terrible and shocking it
seems impossible it controls an area the
size the United Kingdom commits mass
atrocities and launches terror attacks
abroad but to understand Isis it helps
to tell the story of its rise that story
began this far away in many years before
the group existed in 1979 the Soviet
Union invades Afghanistan to defend a
puppet dictator against rebels young men
from the Middle East flock in to join
the rebels many see it as a religious
struggle and some develop extremist
views among them is a well-educated
young Saudi named Osama bin Laden also
in Afghanistan is a semi-literate former
street thug from Jordan who calls
himself Abu Musab al-zarqawi they do not
get along never will but will create the
groups we today know as al-qaeda and
decisis the Soviets withdraw 1989 nearb
fighters eventually go home
bin Laden grows al-qaeda into a global
network to continue the struggle against
his lom's enemies Sakaki forms his own
group but it fizzles but both men later
returned to Afghanistan now ruled by the
Taliban the September 11 2001 akkada
attacks America from its base
the u.s. invades Afghanistan bin Laden
flees to Pakistan circa we still obscure
flees to a remote and lawless corner of
Iraq two years later the u.s. does
something that will transform the Middle
East and set the stage for Isis my
fellow citizens the dangers to our
country and the world will be over the
Americans topple Saddam Hussein's
secular mostly Sunni dictatorship and it
disbands the Iraqi army thousands of
Sunni Iraqi soldiers angry and
unemployed joined the insurgency
jihadist groups who are also Sunni see
this as a repeat of the Soviet invasion
of Afghanistan and again they flood in
to fight Serco is among them
Serco is group eventually becomes Iraq
from most ruthless he especially attacks
Shia deliberately sparking in the
sunni-shia Civil War by 2040 Sarkozy is
a jihadist superstar al-qaeda isolated
and weakened attempts to bolster its
image by forming an alliance with
sakaki's group which becomes known as
al-qaeda and Iraq but in 2006 Iraq's
Sunnis rise up against our Cowie
and the u.s. kills in an airstrike over
the next few years
al-qaeda in Iraq is largely defeated the
Americans withdraw in 2011 from an Iraq
that finally looks stable
2011 the Arab Spring spreads across the
Middle East in Syria dictator Bashar
al-assad cracks down violently on
protesters they eventually fire back
leading to a civil war Assad fears the
world will intervene against him so he
releases jihadists and large numbers of
Syrian prisons changing the rebels with
extremism and making it harder for
foreigners to back them back in Iraq
what little remains of Zarqawi's group
is still allied with al-qaeda but now
known as the Islamic state in Iraq it's
led by a bookish religious scholar who
calls himself Abu Bakr al-baghdadi in
2012
Baghdadi stands atop the deputy to Syria
to start a new al-qaeda branch to fight
alongside the rebels jabhat al-nusra
Baghdadi attacks a series of prisons in
Iraq frees former jihadists and recruits
a new ones growing stronger in April
2013
Baghdadi announces he is taking control
of all al-qaeda Allied forces in Syria
and Iraq
this group expands into Syria becoming
the Islamic State of Iraq and Syria or
Isis al Qaeda rejects Baghdadi's
paragraph and in 2014 formally exiles in
the - jihadist groups long at odds are
now at war
Isis grows powerful in Syria in part
because Assad tolerates its rise which
he does because it divides his enemies
within Syria and because foreign powers
are too focused on Isis now to worry
about Assad by June 2014 Isis has built
an army in Syria and it launches a
military-style invasion into Iraq the
Iraqi army weakened by corruption folds
with little fight and many Sunnis are
tired of their Shia dominated and
increasingly authoritarian government
and welcome or at least tolerate Isis's
arrival within days Isis controls a
third of Iraq and a big part of Syria
Isis's goal is more audacious than
anything imagined by al-qaeda to revive
the ancient Caliphate and expand it to
encompass all Muslims it earnestly
believes it's holy war will then bring
about the apocalypse as foretold in
Scripture thousands of Muslims mostly
from the Middle East and from Europe
flocked to join the group some joined
for religious reasons but many are just
disillusioned or angry and feel that
Isis offers them answers and a purpose
the ISIS quickly overreaches that August
invades Kurdish territory in Iraq and
Syria sparking counter-attacks from
better organized Kurdish forces launches
the genocide against Iraqis and murders
the American journalist James Foley on
camera out raging the world and
provoking an american-led air campaign
against it
Isis can't withstand the onslaught and
loses more than a fifth of its territory
but in response
it begins launching increasingly
spectacular terror attacks abroad in
Tunisia Kuwait Sinai and then Paris and
so-called lone wolves inspired by Isis
propaganda also launched attacks though
they're often amateurish and less
effective eventually Isis will lose its
state is simply too weak has no allies
or outside funders and is surrounded by
enemies but Isis will respond by
reverting to what it was before as al
Qaeda in a month an insurgency and a
terror group still capable of horrifying
violence
in that form could be around for yours
[Music]